[Music]
welcome to the mario kart racing
challenge i'm here with my crew from
mario here also known as team edge my
lover mario mathias and Tyler's over
there don't know why we invited a damn
dirty ape to this race alright so before
this we did a qualifying race to see
what order we were going to start out
the go kart challenges so the order is
wood no here's the results so the order
is Jeff red at eight point one four
seconds here's a neat diagram over
Tyler's face Jake's right no one needs
to see him then it's Brian at eight
point two nine seconds Tyler at eight
point four for mad at eight point seven
eight and me at a glorious nine point
six seven we're now gonna do the Grand
Prix race it's an onslaught endurance
race of a hundred laps we're gonna go as
fast as we can whoever is the winner or
at least doesn't die wins me I'm the
prize so anyway let the race begin
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
so Brian's in first I'm in second person
[Music]
[Applause]
Brian first em in second I don't know
where market I'm winning so they all
crashed into J bread in the corner and I
just wait why are you got
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
DK was the winner if you didn't tell by
him shouting it and then like the
winners thing was thrown in front of
them so now no one's even got a chance
to win but anyway so a dude
he wins me he's gonna take me home so I
count that a win for my team team as can
suck it so thanks everybody for watching
check out their channel for the super
hot challenge if you know the super rock
game we're gonna do that in real life so
links in the description and thanks
again see you in the next one